we are told that the first five
ionization energies for a third period
element are shown below
what is the identity of the element so
pause this video and see if you can
figure it out on your own and it'll
probably be handy to have a periodic
table of elements
so before i even look at a periodic
table of elements let's make sure we
understand what this table is telling us
this is telling us that if we start with
a neutral atom of this mystery element
it would take
578 kilojoules per mole to remove that
first electron to turn that atom into an
ion with a plus one positive charge
and then it would take another 1817
kilojoules per mole to remove a second
electron so to make that ion even more
positive and then after that it would
take another
2745 kilojoules per mole to remove the
third electron
and then to remove the fourth electron
it takes a way larger amount of energy
it takes 11
kilojoules per mole and then the fifth
electron takes even more 14
842 kilojoules per mole
and so for the first second and third
you do have an increase in ionization
energy but when you go to the fourth the
energy required to remove those is way
higher so to me
these look like you're removing valence
electrons
and these look like you're removing core
electrons
so one way to think about it is let's
look at our periodic table of elements
and look for a third period element that
has three valence electrons so we have
our periodic table of elements we want a
third period element so it's going to be
in this third row and which of these has
three valence electrons
well sodium has one valence electron
magnesium has two valence electrons
aluminum has three valence electrons so
one way to think about it is that first
electron it's a reasonable ionization
energy then the second one a little
higher then the third a little bit
higher than after that but then the
fourth you're starting to go into the
core you're going to have to take an
electron out of that full second energy
shell which takes a lot of energy and so
this is pretty clearly
aluminum that is being described